donc bonjour à toutes et à tous ça
marche nickel
j'espère que vous allez bien que pour
l'instant ces petites conférences vous
plaisent et vous intéressent c'est que
la mienne va vous plaire également tout
d'abord je vais me présenter je
m'appelle Théo j'ai 23 ans et je suis
vraiment comme vous tous dans la salle
enfin beaucoup d'entre vous puisque je
suis aussi étudiant en école de commerce
bon moi je suis pas à quel parce que
j'ai pas eu de bonnes notes à mes écrits
donc je suis à la burgundice call of
business à Dijon et je suis ici pour
vous parler un petit peu de YouTube car
depuis 2016 je réalise des vidéos de
géographie géopolitique sur la chaîne là
j'ai ozone comptant 50000 abonnés et 4
millions de vues au total sur la chaîne
vous avez peut-être vu certaines de mes
vidéos comme la pierre ville de France
ou d'autres bien sûr qui ont quand même
pas trop mal marché donc aujourd'hui je
suis là pour vous parler un peu de
YouTube dans sa globalité c'est à dire
qu'on va voir ensemble
comment fonctionne YouTube comment j'ai
commencé mes vidéos ce qui marche
l'argent les sponsos voilà on va essayer
d'avoir des un petit peu tous les sujets
tout d'abord on va voir on va parler un
petit peu de ma chaîne donc comment elle
a commencé comme j'ai dit précédemment
en 2016 vous avez bien suivi et donc
elle part d'un constat simple c'est que
il y a un très peu de gens qui parlent
de géographie sur Youtube et c'est
quelque chose qui me passionne depuis
toujours et il y a un youtubeur qui
commence à en parler vous devez
peut-être le connaître dans la salle
c'est doc seven donc doc seven quelqu'un
qui fait de la vulgarisation
scientifique enfin un peu généraliste
plutôt et donc je me dis ah super il
fait des vidéos de géographiques je suis
refait je regarde depuis ses débuts ça
va être trop bien première vidéo c'est
sur la Suisse je prends une clim
instante parce que je me dis mais la
Suisse finalement on connaît tous déjà
un petit peu on connaît la capitale on
connaît les plus grandes villes on
connaît les lacs etc l'évasion fiscales
et tout donc finalement
c'est déjà quelque chose qui est connu
et moi je suis un petit peu déçu et je
me dis pourquoi je ne ferais pas
l'inverse moi-même à faire des vidéos
sur des pays dont tout le monde se fout
voilà c'est pays dont on parle bon que
quand il y a la guerre et encore et j'ai
fait donc ma première vidéo en 2016 sur
l'Estonie on s'adapte de très très
longtemps donc voilà les vous avez du
courage si vous la regardez et donc j'ai
commencé à faire des vidéos dans ce
style et depuis voici tous les endroits
dont j'ai déjà parlé sur ma chaîne donc
il y a pas beaucoup de grands pays on va
pas se mentir donc ici j'ai présenté des
pays comme je vous ai dit précédemment
il y a par exemple le Suriname le Belize
le Tchad la Norvège le Kirghizistan les
Palaos il y a également aussi des îles
vous avez l'île de bassin vous avez les
Islas de la Baya vous avez la
Nouvelle-Zélande mais il y a aussi des
régions il y a le caracal Pakistan le
cam chat caille ainsi de suite bon là si
vous avez rien compris c'est normal et
c'est pour ça qu'il faut aller voir ma
chaîne abonnez-vous activez la cloche
donc vous vous doutez que
on gagne pas des abonnés comme ça sur
YouTube à moins d'avoir énormément de
chance ou de connaître quelqu'un dans le
milieu donc j'ai commencé à faire mes
vidéos il y a un moment j'en ai fait 130
au total sur ma chaîne dont certaines
qui ont voilà plus ou moins bien marché
voilà si les vidéos qui ont le mieux
marché sur ma chaîne donc on en a quand
même une qui a 350 000 je sais toujours
pas comment mais elle y est donc c'est
très bien et donc voici à quoi
ressemblait ma chaîne en 2020 fin 2020
donc voilà la bannière a une date d'une
autre époque on va dire et donc voilà
j'ai quelques 7000 abonnés tout se passe
très bien dans ma vie je fais des vidéos
depuis 5 ans et juste je les fais pour
moi quoi je me régale et tout ça c'est
un plaisir en fait ça me permettait pour
ma prépa d'avoir d'apprendre de
nouvelles choses que j'ai pu ressortir
pour mes écrits en histoire-géo c'est la
seule matière que j'ai bien réussi
d'ailleurs
et je sors cette vidéo au mois de mai
2021 qui est une vidéo sur les pays qui
sont dans 20 ans et là
je sais pas pourquoi elle marche plus
que les autres voilà on est vraiment au
tout début du pic et après c'est
n'importe quoi en fait je passe de 400
vues par jour à 400 vues par demi heure
donc c'est n'importe quoi et tout se
passe globalement très très bien mais
comme d'hab sur Youtube comprend pas
vraiment pourquoi ça se passe comme ça
et ensuite je me suis dit il faut que je
fasse plus de vidéos parce que une vidéo
enfin là sur le rythme que j'ai c'est
une vidéo toutes les deux semaines
ce que je fais depuis le début de ma
chaîne sauf quand il y a eu mes concours
prépa évidemment et donc je me suis dit
l'année dernière en fin d'année tiens je
vais faire une vidéo par semaine en
novembre et en décembre en plus fin
d'année plus de pub évidemment donc je
me suis régalé et les vidéos ont très
bien marché donc là vous avez un peu
près la période après avril qui a une
petite rechute puis après bon ben
finalement on voit que des vidéos
sortent les unes après les autres et que
ça marche très bien et donc ce qui est
plutôt positif plein de gens viennent
voir mes vidéos je comprends toujours
pas ce qui se passe je me connecte tous
les jours il y a de plus en plus de vues
je me demande où ça va s'arrêter
et après je suis parti en Estonie en
échange universitaire à la boucle est
bouclée avec la première vidéo et j'ai
continué à faire mes petites vidéos
tranquillement toutes les deux semaines
même si entre des petites soirées et
tout ça évidemment donc c'était plus
sympathique et je continue donc toujours
aujourd'hui évidemment
alors
moi je suis ce qu'on appelle un
vulgarisateur alors le terme
vulgarisateur il est un peu pompeux on
va pas se mentir c'est juste que je fais
des vidéos à but éducatives qu'en fait
c'est à dire que normalement vous êtes
censé peut-être potentiellement à
prendre quelque chose si vous regardez
mes vidéos et donc les vulgarisateurs
YouTube les aime bien parce que je sais
pas si vous avez suivi mais il y a une
époque il y a eu quelque chose qui
s'appelle lapocalypse quand les
annonceurs qui mettent leur pub sur
Youtube ont remarqué que leur publicité
passait un peu sur tout et n'importe
quoi comme vidéo donc des mecs qui
faisaient l'apologie du djihad ou des
trucs comme ça donc c'était pas faux et
donc les annonceurs ils sont tous partis
et YouTube a mis en place un robot un
peu vénère pour la monétisation que vous
devez connaître tous les youtubeurs se
plaignent d'être démonétisés H24 à peu
près
et donc
la vulgarisation quand on fait quelque
chose de scientifique c'est quelque
chose qui est très aimé par YouTube
parce que finalement ils nous mettent en
avant on a de la chance comme c'est
quelque chose de très positif voilà
c'est un contenu qui est en soi-disant
intelligent et qui est censé apprendre
des choses aux gens donc c'est de la
bonne pub pour YouTube et donc par
exemple j'ai pu être sélectionné par
Télérama pour faire partie des
youtubeurs donc éducation youtubeur
alors là je suis quand même sur une page
j'ai 6000 abonnés à l'époque et je suis
à côté de Manon brille de Nota Bene et
de Charlie d'Angers je sais pas ce que
je fais là mais je suis là quoi et donc
voilà une expérience plutôt cool ensuite
j'ai pu rencontrer Jamie gourmot à une
Master Class de YouTube avec le CNC donc
Centre national du cinéma et d'images
animées et Arte donc voilà petit goal de
fou dans la vie quand même c'est plutôt
pas mal
il y a encore 10 jours j'ai visité
l'opéra de la Bastille à Paris et
rencontrer des institutions culturelles
donc c'est à dire le château de
Versailles le Louvre la Philharmonie de
Paris etc etc et également
j'ai pu participer à des conventions ou
des conférences à Épinal avec la région
Grand Est je suis allé à Albi pour
parler des métiers de la géographie je
suis dans une liste du ministère de
l'Éducation sur les vidéastes
utilisables en cours enfin voilà donc
c'est plutôt très cool de la
vulgarisation sur YouTube
maintenant si jamais vous voulez réussir
brosser ça marche ça parle de YouTube
mais ça marche si vous voulez faire du
twitch du TikTok ce que vous voulez
comment réussir alors là j'espère que
vous êtes prêt à prendre des notes parce
que c'est un vrai faux conseil vous
allez voir pour réussir sur Youtube
c'est assez simple il faut faire des
vidéos souvent
et qui vous plaisent donc voilà c'est
pour ça que je vous disais que c'était
un faux conseil parce que à mon époque
on disait déjà les mêmes choses enfin
les youtubeurs qui avaient marché
disaient déjà les mêmes choses et je me
disais mais se foutent de nous quoi en
fait voilà c'est juste des phrases
bateaux pour nous faire croire des
choses mais en fait c'est vraiment le
cas parce que la réussite compte
beaucoup sur la régularité si on arrête
de faire des vidéos pendant x temps les
vues vont forcément baisser et donc on
sera moins mis en avant quand la vidéo
encore une autre vidéo sortira donc il
faut se tenir un planning et pour se
tenir un planning et faire des vidéos
mais il faut faire quelque chose qui
nous plaît tout simplement ça me paraît
assez bête de le dire comme ça mais
effectivement si jamais vous faites des
vidéos qui ne vous intéressent pas ou
sur un sujet qui vous passionne pas ou
que vous le faites juste pour l'argent
ou l'algorithme finalement ça va pas
marcher bizarrement et donc vous aurez
plus envie d'en faire puisque ça vous
intéresse pas donc voilà ce sont les
deux clés après j'ai vu une un TEDx
d'une youtubeuse canadienne qui dit
tranquille que en gros pour réussir sur
youtube il fallait commencer il y a 6
ans alors oui effectivement c'est un peu
plus compliqué aujourd'hui il y a
beaucoup de monde sur toutes les
plateformes
mais bien sûr si jamais vous faites
enfin faut pas partir de toute façon du
postulat que si vous faites que vous
faites du YouTube ou quoi que ce soit
c'est pour réussir sinon c'est évident
que ça ne marchera jamais bien sûr
alors la réussite c'est pas que de faire
des vidéos souvent et que vous amusiez
c'est aussi de la chance parce qu'il y a
quelque chose qui s'appelle l'algorithme
sur Youtube je pense que vous demandez
ce que c'est et bien nous aussi on se
demande ce que c'est ça tombe bien parce
qu'en fait le lieu l'algorithme c'est
une grosse boîte noire qui va faire que
ta vidéo elle marche ou ta vidéo elle
marche pas souvent elle marche pas donc
en fait ça va mettre sur les
recommandations qui est à droite des
vidéos sur YouTube en vous disant oui
vous pouvez vous voulez vous voir cette
vidéo et tout ça et donc l'algorithme on
sait pas trop comment il fonctionne
c'est à dire que est-ce que ça compte le
nombre le nombre de personnes qui ont vu
la vidéo le pourcentage de la vidéo qui
est vu les gens qui ont liké qui ont
commenté donc c'est pour ça que tous vos
youtubeurs vous demandent de lâcher un
gros pouce bleu après la vidéo voilà
c'est pour essayer de nourrir
l'algorithme parce que peut-être que ça
marche on est vraiment pas sûr mais bon
peut-être
et donc l'algorithme c'est vraiment
juste du hasard en fait des fois comme
ma vidéo sur les 20 pays qui sont dans
20 ans bah ça marche et tant mieux et
c'est trop bien et finalement ça
continue ça continue ça engrange et
d'autres vidéos bah juste ça va se ça va
pas marcher quoi elles vont partir puis
finalement comme les premières personnes
au début on va pas regarder ce sera
moins bien d'avance sur celle d'après
puis sur celle d'après puis finalement
les vidéos elles marchent un petit peu
moins donc voilà finalement je peux pas
vous dire que réussir c'est juste faire
des vidéos parce que c'est un peu
délusional parce qu'en fait il y a pas
de méritocratie sur Youtube quand des
youtubeurs vont vous faire des FAQ et
vous faire vous savez moi j'ai tout
donné sur Youtube j'ai sacrifié des
heures de ma vie juste pour ça et un
jour j'ai réussi donc vous pouvez le
faire c'est du bullshit évidemment ça ne
marche pas comme ça en fait parce que il
faut avoir ce petit ce petit coup de
pouce du destin qui va vous faire
fonctionner et
j'ai les gens qui disent ça je trouve ça
assez irrespectueux pour tous les autres
parce que on voit tous ceux qui ont
réussi évidemment vous les connaissez
tous mais ceux qui ont abattu des heures
de fou qui se sont donnés à fond pour
faire des vidéos qui ont cru jusqu'au
bout mais leur vidéo elles ont jamais
marché et vous les avez jamais vu et ça
c'est le plus triste j'en ai des amis
vidéastes qui faisaient des super vidéos
et du jour au lendemain
tu te signe de vie voilà ils ont tous
arrêté parce que une vidéo ça prend deux
mois à faire et que quand ça prend deux
mois à faire la vidéo elle marche pas
forcément tu arrêtes forcément c'est
c'est un peu embêtant bon après avec les
études les cours et tout ça forcément ça
n'aide pas
et donc l'algorithme en fait c'est un
petit peu enfin moi j'aime bien comparer
ça à des croyants qui vont mettre des
offrandes sur un hôtel c'est-à-dire que
vraiment c'est les pouces bleus ils vont
les mettre sur un hôtel et ils vont
espérer que le grand dieu de youtube il
va toucher leur vidéo et faire ah
celle-là elle va marcher donc voilà en
sachant que il y a du hasard mais
évidemment il y a aussi des opportunités
qui se créent et il faut savoir les
saisir donc c'est pas forcément que au
hasard mais voilà par exemple moi je
suis ici devant vous c'est une
opportunité de fou de faire un TDX on va
pas se mentir
voilà j'avais cours désolé à mon école
s'il regarde mais je suis venu voilà
évidemment je veux dire j'allais pas
j'allais pas ne pas venir pour ça donc
voilà effectivement il faut saisir ces
opportunités
après il y a quelque chose qui s'appelle
later alors moi je fais des vidéos de
géographiques vous allez vous dire que
ça devrait aller mais figurez-vous que
ça non en gros quand j'ai fait des
vidéos il y a très longtemps sur les
dictatures et j'ai eu le malheur de
parler de l'Iran alors l'Iran dans la
situation actuelle en plus ça tombe bien
et
j'ai reçu des commentaires de toute la
communauté chiite francophone quand en
gros qui me dit qu'est-ce que tu dis
c'est pas une dictature etc etc on m'a
souhaité d'aller mourir enfin c'était
super cool et
je me souviens allez voir mon prof
d'histoire-géo en prépa et lui faire
monsieur l'Iran c'est une dictature et
comme si j'avais besoin de son
approbation pour valider vraiment que je
disais pas que du bullshit donc voilà
bon ça peut arriver souvent j'ai aussi
fait une vidéo sur les wiggours donc
évidemment enfin je parle même pas en
plus des Ouigours de ce qui se passe et
tout ça mais vraiment de l'aspect
géopolitique qui a derrière et que
personne n'en parle vraiment et ne peut
les défendre à cause de la pression
chinoise et là il y a des gens qui me
disent que c'est normal qu'il y a pas du
tout de souci là-dedans et tout ça donc
je me suis vraiment posé pas mal de
questions à pas se mentir et donc on a
ces petits outils qui sont bien utiles
qui permettent de supprimer
de bannir les personnes de la chaîne
c'est à dire qui commentent mais
personne n'allait voir donc ça c'est
plutôt pratique
ensuite on va forcément parler un petit
peu d'argent parce que les gros sou ça
fait toujours parler évidemment
il y a plein de youtubeurs qui n'en
parlent pas parce que forcément dire que
tu gagnes 10000 euros par mois c'est un
peu mal vu en France on va pas se mentir
et il y en a qui en parle mais bon à
demi-mot quoi je me rappelle d'une vidéo
de Tibo inshape je pense que vous
connaissez tous dans la salle qui avait
dit je cite qui touchait qui se versait
500 euros par mois
voici ce que j'ai gagné au mois de
juillet donc 530 euros j'ai 50000
abonnés j'ai fait 200000 vues quand tu
fais un million de vues par vidéo vous
doutez qui touche pas 100 euros donc on
nous prend un peu pour des pigeons
cependant à chaque fois il faut dire
mais non je touche X mais en fait ça va
dans ma boîte puis après l'État prend la
moitié puis après je prends je me verse
un salaire évidemment il vit à Albi donc
je pense que 500 euros ça peut le faire
mais logiquement sa chaîne fait plus que
500 euros sinon c'est n'importe quoi et
parfois il y a des petits miracles donc
au mois de décembre dernier j'ai fait
beaucoup de vues donc plus de 600 000 et
j'ai touché au total
1700 euros
me demandez pas comment ça se fait mais
moi je ne sais toujours pas d'ailleurs
mais avec les fêtes avec les vues qui
ont bien fonctionné donc j'ai pu dégager
pas mal c'était on va pas se mentir
c'est plutôt sympa surtout quand on est
étudiant et donc c'est quelque chose qui
est toujours toujours bienvenu pour
mettre un peu de beurre dans les
épinards et voilà donc c'est pour vous
faire relativiser que j'ai 50 000
abonnés je ne vis pas du tout de ça
aujourd'hui et je peux toucher ça donc
vous vous doutez que les gros youtubeurs
qui font un million de vues par vidéo
qui en font trois par semaine bon voilà
ils se mettent pas trop mal on va pas se
mentir bon après forcément ils ont
peut-être des projets à côté et tout ça
et pour gagner aussi de l'argent il y a
d'autres moyens comme faire des vidéos
de pluie de 8 minutes c'est pour ça que
vous voyez des vidéos de 8 minutes 01
bien évidemment parce qu'on peut mettre
des pubs pendant la vidéo tout
simplement et aussi des vidéos
sponsorisées
alors moi j'en ai fait deux doper sur ma
chaîne depuis ma création j'ai fait une
vidéo pour des cours de langue en ligne
et une pour des bracelets et bijoux en
bois et métal et Pierre et à chaque fois
je demandais de tester des produits
quand je connaissais pas dans les deux
je connaissais pas d'ailleurs pour
tester pour voir si c'est pas de la
merde comme on dit parce que c'est quand
même dommage de vendre quelque chose qui
ne marche pas ses abonnés bien
évidemment et aujourd'hui c'est vraiment
rentré dans les mœurs finalement les
vidéos sponsorisées on en voit beaucoup
et beaucoup me disent que je pourrais en
faire plus pour vivre de mes vidéos
comme je le dis je vous touche je touche
un mysmique et une vidéo ça rapporte
aussi à peu près un mystique quand les
sponsorisés
donc ça pourrait potentiellement
permettre d'en vivre mais moi je suis
pas fan de faire toutes les vidéos
sponsorisées parce que moi je regarde
beaucoup de vidéos sur YouTube peut-être
que certains dans la salle aussi
beaucoup et je sais pas mais moi quand
je vois une sponso par vidéo juste à me
rendre dingue vraiment j'ai juste envie
d'appuyer sur la petite flèche de droite
pour ce qui fait à la moitié de la vidéo
donc forcément c'est pas faux
donc avant que cette petite partie se
termine je voulais juste rappeler que en
fait sur youtube il y a de tout et c'est
très bien comme ça là je vous parle de
la vulgarisation mais c'est pas pour
dénigrer tous ceux qui font du contenu
soit disant facile comme on peut en voir
par exemple des hauls des tags ce genre
de choses là n'oubliez pas que il y a
pas de vraiment de règle de ah ça c'est
du bon contenu ça c'est du contenu
pourri je veux dire si jamais YouTube
est une plateforme comme on la connaît
aujourd'hui qui plait autant de monde et
qui rassemble autant c'est parce qu'il y
a une liberté de création aussi grande
et que vous pouvez trouver des vidéos de
géographiques des tags et du tricot
voilà merci à tous
[Applaudissements]